[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie I got a lot of
requests to do a video for all this
Titans episode 1 stuff that dropped I'm
always a little suspicious when stuff
like this happens so grain of salt I'll
talk about the non spoilery stuff but it
gives you a good idea for where the
characters pick up how they explain
their backstories and what it looks and
feels like there are a couple things
that are missing in this breakdown I
don't know if they've changed the edit
from what this description is but
because it's been in the can for so long
I imagine that they've changed minor
edit several times so for instance Beast
Boy supposedly does not appear in the
pilot episode it's mostly dedicated to
you cannonballing into the world with
Robin Raven and star fires characters
but sort of teeing up what the big
overarching story is going to be with
the Church of Blood and what's going on
with star fires character but if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the DC videos
there's a new round of the Legion ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber leave a comment
on the video what'll happen is is when
the DC streaming service drops is all
two giveaways for memberships of that
whatever it ends up costing no worries
and I will explain the delay for Young
Justice season 3 at the end of the video
too because there's a lot of questions
about why they pushed it back but when
you're thinking about Titans if you've
ever wondered why the DC TV crossovers
always work so well and why they don't
just make a show that's just that with
them doing the crossover every single
week
that's what Titans is meant to be 13
one-hour movies so the look of it the
feel of it is way more hardcore than
anything you would see on a show like
arrow which is probably the most
hardcore DC TV show and the special
effects are so much better than what you
see on the flash and Supergirl like one
of the big criticisms of flash is that
sometimes they're overly ambitious
special effects wind up looking like ps2
graphics some of the extra lead time and
getting Titans out like why it's taken
so long to make it is because they're
spending so much extra time to make the
special effects look like movie quality
there's reports of all kinds of F bombs
being dropped the violence being much
more graphic imagine a version of the
Batman warehouse scene from Batman V
Superman
whatever you think about the rest of the
movie that is probably one of the best
Batman comic book bites of all time so
imagine a TV series that flows from that
type of energy I feel like they've done
really good stunts on arrow that's one
of their strong points because they
don't do a lot of special effects but
imagine you blend the best fight scenes
with the best special effects from DC TV
and put that into a big team-up show
with some of the biggest characters from
DC Comics and I'll get into this too as
we talk about Ravens character on the
series she's one of the most powerful
characters that they've ever introduced
from the comics obviously Robins
character is the first one you meet he's
the most important character in the
series next to ravens character they do
a good job of explaining how he's not
with Batman anymore the interesting
surprises is that this description puts
him in San Francisco I don't know if
that's accurate if you're not a big
comic book reader the reason why San
Francisco is an important city in the DC
Universe is because that is where the
current version of the Titans tower
exists that's where the Titans home base
is the weird thing is is they've been
filming the last couple of episodes
though and we've seen a whole lot of
Gotham City
maybe they bounce back and forth between
cities during the rest of the episodes
the way they describe Batman in the
series is he appears in the pilot
episode as a shadow like a hallucination
Robin will turn around and think that he
sees him but it turns out that nothing's
there so it's sort of like that Batman
trick where he's there and then all of a
sudden you spin around and he disappears
when we meet him he's in his mid to late
20s so I'm guessing that his Batman is
like really late 30s early 40s a little
bit younger than Ben Affleck's Batman we
get a couple action scenes that
highlight his more acrobatic fighting
style imagine like a more hardcore
version of the way that Steven Amell
fights on arrow along with the
acrobatics of the Dick Grayson character
from the comics there's also supposed to
be a flashback to flying Grayson's just
to give you a version of the origin
story all the characters are supposed to
get versions of that to a certain degree
but obviously Robins the most important
so you get the deepest dive on his
character you meet a couple of his
supporting characters like Detective
Rohrbach she's actually from the Chuck
Dixon Nightwing comics in Bludhaven so I
don't know if Bludhaven figures into the
series because this keeps describing San
Francisco they might just be changing
that part and put her in San Francisco
then they jumped to ravens character and
you get the
same version of the origin story that
you got for Robyn's character you learn
about her mother you get to see how
strung out they are how messed up she is
she's a relatively younger version of
the character so her powers haven't
fully manifested but they do give you a
version of that Scarlet Witch
age of Ultron post-credits scene where
you get a taste for her powers like
telepathy and telekinesis but she can do
way more than that eventually when she
becomes older she gains the power of
flight she can teleport astral
projection she's a master of dark magic
she's one of the most powerful
characters in the DC Universe so it's
gonna be pretty cool but they also
introduce you to her supporting
characters through the Church of blood
there's a character called the acolyte
which is supposed to be a relatively big
character during season one
he's from the Church of blood in the
comics brother blood is a character
during the series it sounds like they're
trying to capture Raven so they can
perform the ritual to bring Trigon into
this universe but then you jump to
Starfire's character and the weird thing
about the way this person is explaining
the Starfire character is that she's
dressed like 70s Starfire because she's
at a party so there's a parody aspect to
it but through her characters they set
off the main arc that will cause them to
form the Titans team so if they're not
gonna use Beast Boy in the first episode
that might be why because they're
introducing so much mythology and trying
to set up so many big arcs it sounds
like it's not going to exclusively deal
with the Church of blood so they'll be
other problems but remember Starfire has
an evil sister Blackfyre who's actually
trying to get rid of her because she's
the heir to the throne of her homeworld
the way they describe the Starfire
character is that you get a really big
action scene towards the end of the
episode remember at the end of the first
episode of the flash where he has that
big tornado that he has to take down
look you have one really big action set
piece you can do this
[Music]
it sounds like the big action set piece
of this episode takes place through the
Starfire character when she manifests
her powers so I'm guessing that she's
gonna be crazy powerful during the
series they don't say a whole lot about
what her official costume is gonna look
like it sounds like Robin is one of the
few people that wears a traditional
superhero costume when the series picks
up then Corey will just get a bunch of
different costume changes mostly she
doesn't wear a lot of clothes that's the
whole thing about the character so she
walks around half naked so it'll be fun
to see how they deal with that if this
is meant to be a more hardcore series
I'm not expecting them to do titans
tower during season one they might tease
it at the end of the season and then
just have them build it in a future
season but originally what happened is
is the first version of the Titans Tower
was built by cyborgs father he was a
founding member of the Teen Titans so
his father built the first Titans tower
that was in New York City
Trigon destroyed it then a while later
they rebuilt it in San Francisco where
it's been ever since the only things
that they don't talk about in this
description of the first episode is is
what the theme song sounds like which is
obviously a very important thing and
what the music in general is going to be
I feel like right now Black Lightning
probably has the best DC TV music I have
very high expectations for titans but
obviously it's probably not gonna all be
hip-hop music the way that black
lightning is I'm expecting it to be very
different I talked a little bit about
the launch dates in my last big trailer
video I'll link that at the end of this
but we also found out that they pushed
the premiere of Young Justice it was
originally supposed to premiere towards
the end of this year but now they're
saying 2019 I'm guessing because they
want to give Titans more time to air or
they're planning on premiering it a
couple weeks after they originally were
like when they say it's delayed to 2019
that doesn't mean it's gonna be a full
year it just means it's gonna be early
2019 so just remember there's gonna be a
Young Justice season 3 comic-con panel
where hopefully the creators will have
more news about that leave all your
video requests in the comments below
click here to rewatch that trailer and
click here for brand new Avengers 4
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight